it's a realization that weighs heavy on
pies on [ __ ] he came within a whisker of
getting trapped himself but the 13 year
old didn't join his teammates for the
cave trip his mother didn't allow it so
he stayed behind avoiding the fate of
his friends and their coach my best
friend tan is in the cave he's the
smallest one but one of the best players
I miss him I'd like to see how he is my
son's family belongs to the akka an
indigenous hill tribe in the region
their religion is strongly influenced by
animism and ancestor worship by Sean's
mother believes that an evil spirit lies
within the cave that's why she told her
son not to go opening he may be like I'm
so happy that he obeyed my orders he's
generally a very quiet and well-behaved
boy not a troublemaker I'm so grateful I
don't have to worry about him now for
the past two weeks Python has been glued
to his smartphone most of the time
following any update and the rescue
efforts he's confident that he will see
all of his friends again I want the
matter as soon as possible so that we
can play soccer again since the group
went missing there hasn't been any
regular soccer practice
but paesan and some of his friends keep
on playing they say it helps to take
their mind off things but for them it's
not about winning or losing on the pitch
at the moment they're rooting for their
friends hoping they can pull off their
biggest victory yet